you know the amount of giving that is
being done in the world that is
disguised as manipulation to get
something that you want after you give
is the reason that giving has cynicism
around it you got your perspective first
just want to thank everybody for being
here I'm sure there's you could have
been anywhere in the world tonight but
you decided to be here so I appreciate
that I'd love to do as much Q&A as
possible I think for you know anybody in
the audience whatever the questions are
and whatever genres if you want to talk
about the New York Jets American
football that is something I can speak
to or anything else you'd like to speak
to about but you know just having a
sense of the audience and knowing
there's a mix of entrepreneurship and a
mix of corporate in this journey that
you're going through when you know I'm
always fascinated when someone does
something I think that the most
interesting things I see in the world
are more based on counterpunching skills
than they are on the game plan you had
going into the fight right I think the
ability to recognize the collateral from
your movement as a person or as an
organization or as a business and
contextualizing it to the reality of
what's happening not the hypothesis or
thesis you came into it is SuperDuper
important and and I would argue a very
important thing for every person in this
room whether professionally personally
to think about because that's then
practical instead of pontificating or a
hypothesis for you going through this
you start something you decide you start
a hashtag you know you know if you met
me on day one and said hey I'm gonna do
this hashtag I would've been like bro
don't do a hash tag hash tags are not
ownable like you can put it out there
but right now I can use your hash tag to
syphon the people are paying attention
to that to sell a razor I could like any
they're not ownable but what I wanted to
ask that I thought could bring the most
value to this group is what's been the
biggest surprise as you've gone through
this journey like what did you ideology
wise have in your head three years ago
that's just fundamentally different
today
yes sir that's a really really good
point because for me I just I guess
that's what I can
hands up say I did not have going into
this is like that kickback questions
once I just went in with an idea and
went outside executing it and that was
that but the biggest surprise for me for
sure has been though this the tiniest
amount of people have kicked up against
this and I mean that in a way of like
the competitive world of charity and
business and all kinds of different
things I have felt almost zero
competition in what I'm doing and
although it's like super important to
I've thought plenty of times like yes
just a hashtag anyone could take do
something for nothing and do what they
want with it but I kind of want them to
do that I want them to go ahead and do
exactly that and I suppose there's
enough populating this already that you
can see what it's about and I feel so
lucky the fact that there's already
enough of a journey to go if someone
tried to come in and it wasn't authentic
I think it would be read out pretty much
immediately but the biggest surprise
honestly has been the amount deal the
small amount of haters I've had is
quickly transitioned into I feel like
people who who see this water is and I
don't think that's anything to do with
me personally I think it's just the I'm
not trying to shout anyone I'm just
saying here's how I'm doing it just
playing the amplifier and it seems to
like have worked it sounds like a bit of
a [ __ ] way to say Oh nothing's go
wrong that's the biggest surprise well I
I think you know people I speak about
that too I mean I think nothing goes
wrong when you don't have expectation
you know I think people I think people
have a lot of things going wrong because
they [ __ ] expected something it's why
people struggle with giving giving is
giving on the person that you're giving
it to term is not yours you know the
amount of giving that is being done in
the world that is disguised as
manipulation to get something that you
want after you give is the reason that
giving has cynicism around it it's not
giving it's manipulation to me to me
what we you know we were talking
something to share we were just jamming
a little bit upstairs you know something
that I've been affected by in just
giving or social good or we got into
brands and business talk a little bit is
that you know the the biggest issue to
me about you know companies and social
good have not been the biggest companies
in the world it's been the startups who
are using good as a front to their
financial ambitions the amount of
companies after Tom's was successful
hyper Sinhalese and I was kind of
slowing down my investing during this
period I personally sat through 40 to 70
pitches where the person walked in and
said some sob story about why they were
so passionate about the redheaded aunt
you know the insect in Afghanistan and
how every time somebody bought this Cola
they would donate a Cola to that aunt or
the kid or this and that and then when I
looked at the economics around the
business they weren't giving jack [ __ ]
they inflated the price of the product
so much that they were able to make
their full margin and then give back
whatever they were fear I mean as we all
know there's been plenty of buy one give
one and and it got me so cynical to the
majority of the altruistic entrepreneur
who was using good as a front and I
think we have a we have a lot of
understanding that when big brands do
things were always cynical but to me
they've been dramatically better social
players than the entrepreneurs who are
out there fronting that they're saving
the world but they really just give a
[ __ ] about their economics yeah and I
think I think I see so many people like
day to day in the work I do like I see
people really killing it all the time
and no eyes are on them whatsoever like
I see people who are absolutely smashing
in that compute communities every single
day and no eyes are on them and I think
that actually I agree and that's what we
were saying upstairs I think when you
have a front and it kind of hasn't got
the guts and the kind of anything else
to offer I think it is even worse
because they're using something as a
mask that really shouldn't be used as a
mask it's really about people and it's
about one another so I think the way
I've seen the brands are turning and
helping is being able to find those
change makers be able to find those
individuals who are already doing it in
their communities and be able to
highlight them and support them in a way
because I mean so many people who need
that support but they just they're just
doing it and they're not expecting it
but they could probably do a hell of a
lot
or if they had that engine so yeah I
think it's um I think it's important to
kind of recognize those people maybe who
were already I mean and as far as having
too many ideas going in maybe people do
I don't know I've had that experience
where people have maybe had this
foolproof plan about how they're going
to give and I guess for me it's just
about going out there and I just talk to
people I just have a conversation you
know that's what I think literally I'm
not doing anything like I'm I'm up here
because of a journey I'm not up here
because I'm any I talk to people I have
a conversation I look I say hello to
people that's what I do
you know yes I mean I think I think one
of the fascinating things about so I'm
pretty uncomfortable
you know it's funny I'm so comfortable
publicizing I want to buy a sports
franchise but I'm outrageously
uncomfortable and a lot of my inner
circles curious about um I'm
uncomfortable talking about the things I
do and nonprofit I I once had - after I
got into a huge Twitter rant seven years
ago meet somebody at a Starbucks and
show them my tax return because I got
into this like TIFF nonetheless it was
what why I bring that up is I'm
fascinated by people what people want to
talk about don't want to talk about it I
think that's up to everybody but in that
same parallel a thing that became more
obvious to me is it's stunning that at
this point in my life it's far more easy
for me to write a check to a non-profit
than sit on the boards that I'm on or
actually give time right I think it's
you know and and by the way I tell my
when I say that a lot of times my friend
I had a friend who heard me say that in
some podcasts and he like hit me up I
got in fun with him he's like man I feel
bad I should start doing some volatile I
grow I'll be honest with you like plenty
of organizations need money like like
this is not about like one or the other
it's just like what do you have to give
like a lot of startup people like I
don't have money I'm like you have your
time like you want to build a business
and you have no money good news
you have your time like go reply to
every single person on Twitter talking
about your topic like like that's what I
did like you know you got one or the
other I think when I think about giving
I think a lot about time or money just
like I do with businesses and I think
that's an interesting another thing that
I've been spending a lot of time
thinking about
yeah and that's I'm so glad you touched
on that because it's like it's it's it's
you are identifying what your time is
and how its best
as well like I mean a lot of people will
message me again touch with me be like
you know come out of you on the street
and hang out or like let's go out and
give give give on the street people and
I'm like this guy Franco's here tonight
he's who's helping me he just came out
of the woodwork from nowhere and he's
like I'm an editor someone's used me I'm
like that's so valuable oh my god I've
got someone to help me edit some stuff
for the first time ever I'm like oh god
that's incredible I mean I'm just saying
that's just one example of like you and
your time can be spent all kinds of ways
it's gonna again bring people up and
kind of help like direct help this this
goes back to giving it's funny because
I'm sure you get hit up by people were
like hey I want to go out with you
mm-hmm
and because what they want is they want
to go out with you take a selfie with
you get the awareness that they were
with you because they think you're cool
or it's cool and that's what they're
actually trying to accomplish this goes
back to like giving on the other
person's terms I mean I literally get
700 emails a month when somebody knows
I'm gonna be in some town like Gary
like in the title like great news I will
pick you up from the airport and drive
you to your hotel I want to really give
I'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm like
that's $48 uber ride I need my peace and
quiet to catch up with the work when I
land from the flight you don't want to
give me a ride you want me to give you
[ __ ] consulting for 45 minutes while
we drive you can save your lunch that
you want me to buy that you want to buy
for me and all that and I'm fascinated
by you know and a lot of times I'll hit
up those kids they're like yo it's not
working I'm like cuz you're not giving
when you're DMing somebody you're asking
you're trying to take like you know it's
it's really it's a really funny thing to
try to get somebody to click on what the
definition of giving is and people
struggle with selflessness they really
do they leave they struggle with not
being selfish in the disguise of giving
and i think ii think the reason i want
to talk about it and keep throwing out
these examples is once you're aware of
it people aren't even oftentimes aren't
aware you know but once you become aware
of it i actually think it changes the
entire framework of this conversation
you know so I think giving and I used
you know whether you selflessness or
giving for me it's like what do you want
right like if I'm gonna give or if I'm
gonna be something like if I'm doing
something for you it can't be what I
think you need it can't be what I have
to give you or what's convenient for me
to give you it has to be what you want
what you need the other party if you're
giving the other party needs that thing
and so that's the part that keeps
playing over and over in my head like
you know giving with expect the two core
things I'm fascinated by is people are
great at giving when they have something
to give but if the other person doesn't
want it that's not giving and then much
scarier to me the one that I'm most
cynical to is I'm gonna give to you
right now because I have something I
want from you and three even if you're
strategic and in three and a half years
there's something I want from you I
don't mind if somebody's thoughtful and
can conceive that they're maybe I even
do that I do things that like oh this
could it's that I don't expect a hundred
thousand percent uh you know what's
funny I've thought about that a little
bit I'm not sure but [ __ ] I'd much
rather that be the case than the
alternative right like I'd much rather
people struggle that they're that
they're you know with how they're giving
versus being having a loaded gun on
they're giving you know what I mean like
I think that you know for me I've come
to learn that I like admiration I want
to statue I don't want money right and
so so my selfishness is that I want to
be admired and liked and appreciated and
thus I've defaulted into giving right
you know in whatever way I think about
it like but yeah I think it's a very
interesting I you know it's fun because
I know there's a lot of business people
here
it's how I mark it I think it's all very
tied together it's being consumer
centric it's being human centric I think
giving is a really important like
concept because I think the way people
have it framed is so much
more selfish I'm gonna share something
I've shared very few times in my life
that's right
probably the single biggest
disappointing moment in my life of
something I absolutely did not see at
all
and when I was faced with it just like
took the wind out of my body was when I
started joining nonprofit boards and
realized almost everybody that was there
to network with people to do [ __ ] in the
outside world in business not because
they were there for the giving I wrote a
book called Jab Jab Jab right hook for a
very specific reason I thought the best
way to market is to give give give and
then ask and not expect not giving it
given than take when you when you give
you give when you're asking you're
asking don't be half pregnant in your
giving don't be half pregnant in your
ask when you want to sell something it
just crushed me and it you know was like
literally the second meeting I ever had
first one was a little weird second one
I kind of looked around during like you
know it's a three-hour board meeting
we're trying to save build schools in
Ghana and then I'm just listening to
what everybody's actually saying when
they're grabbing fruit or going for a
pee break and I'm like [ __ ] it crushed
me and then I saw it again heavily with
the bots when Tom's was successful the
give what like that was very obvious to
me and I see companies doing it all the
time
companies like companies are trying to
be good or be more diverse or do the
right thing their companies they're
trying to make money and like we sense
it but I think we are cynical to big
companies and I think we need to be more
thoughtful about individual humans
because humans are hiding students are
hiding and I think if humans understood
how life actually works which is when
you have something give and you give and
you give without expectation when you
truly right I mean it this is what I
sensed from our Jam I think it's working
for you because you literally have no
[ __ ] expectation and my own
expectations is literally when I go
sleep at night I'm just like my
expectation is that guy I've seen that
day and how he fell and how I felt like
it's
so low and I know some people were like
my benchmark is so low on what is a good
day for me and that sounds really awful
it's really really not it's just I said
it somewhere that's it's completely
based on my own expectation and that's
that's exactly where it is but for me
for me I just I just see I see the like
having time for one another whether
that's a company or whether that's an
individual I just think I guess it's
harder to see with a bigger brand like I
know it needs a bit more of a buffer to
be able to create those store to be able
to like we've all seen those campaigns
that go wrong and like we've questioned
them and I think sometimes that doesn't
need a buffer and a bridge and I've been
in positions before where I have been
like should I do this because I don't
know where that ruins what I'm doing and
it's is a difficult place but I know
that it's definitely worth creating more
of a space for these things and that's
why I wanted to kind of leave and ask
you Gary's what do you feel as far as
putting this stuff out like I put this
out on social media all the time my
Instagram is full of this stuff I'm
doing where I'm like I'm doing something
for someone else
and obviously that's a very kind of like
some of you might be thinking now it's
like oh no song man this is great but
like telling a little hell of a lot of
people I thought how nice you're being
to someone and I try and keep it
somewhere that's very much about I guess
like I said these people but I think I
think you know I'm just gonna jump in
different I think it's intent I think
it's intent like Gary you're such a
narcissist all your content is you I'm
like I'm trying to say something to
people that I hope they take and I
expect nothing from them I ask nothing
of them and I hope they take it and do
something with it that is the form of
how I know how to communicate it I'm
sorry I'm in the video like you like if
you were trying to get everybody to
watch so that youth everybody here
thought you were the best guy so then
you could rope-a-dope um and get them
into some sort of like $5,000 a month
Club to be good then you're a [ __ ]
if you don't and you live your life and
you do it and then you die
you're the best I'm not joking I think
intent is the thing I put my head on the
pillow I think I'm gonna make mistakes
every day I will make mistakes I am a
human I will do things that are wrong I
am a human I will say I'm sorry when I'm
wrong
I will take losses when I deserve them
but the intent is [ __ ] amazing like
it's why I'm so [ __ ] calm
it's why I'm happiest [ __ ] it's why I'm
so grateful it's why I'm able to give
because I'm so fulfilled that like I
give out of guilt and gratitude right
like I'm just I know exactly what's
happening with me and I'm trying to get
people to change into perspective but
I'm really not trying to like I like the
feeling of somebody getting benefit from
something you said that's what I'm sure
that gets you excited like watching
somebody go do something meaningful
because they thought it was cool that
you cut somebody's like that's an
incredible feeling yeah it's amazing
yeah he gives me all the hope in the
world that's what motivates me to carry
on doing this every time someone takes
this and does their own thing with it
that's exactly it so I agree I think
that's the thing that I admire about you
in the limited time and context I have
for you that I think is important to
make me palpable that I would highly
recommend people think about is what is
your level of humility like I say it I
said it in the four DS just now what
some feel like it really meant it like
if I die tomorrow I think I'll have a
good three hour run on social media
where everybody will share their
favorite piece of content or whatever
whatever it might be and literally every
single person that is even my superest
fan and consumes me 30 hours a day a
week later will be on to their life and
I think when you actually like I'm
trying to [ __ ] I want to impact seven
point seven billion people that is my
ambition my ambition is to share what my
mom did so well with me and pass it on
and my mom my dad my circumstances but
really my [ __ ] mom the way she
parented me in that optimism and
positivity but with accountability right
that balance which I think we've lost in
modern parenting if I can share that
impact people get them into perspective
like I push out my content like four
hundred trillion to one look if you like
who likes math and here you should be
happy as [ __ ] because when I tell you
that your likelihood of being born is
400 trillion to one and you go and do
the math behind it and actually accept
the modern science behind this which is
400 trillion to 1 if you actually wrap
your [ __ ] head around the fact that
we're all humans and we're sitting here
right now and the likelihood of that is
literally impossible oh I don't know all
of a sudden [ __ ] get
happy I'm being serious I'm being real
serious people like why are you so happy
I'm like if 13 people didn't die today
everything else is manageable I really
live my life that way and that leads to
happy but it's perspective and that lets
you but that is my goal my goal is the
wiring and serendipity of my DNA now
that there's an internet I'm like [ __ ]
it let me share it at scale I enjoy it I
like getting stopped at the airport at
somebody saying you cheat like I love it
and I'm gonna do it and I'm and I want
to reach all seven point seven billion
people I mean it with all my heart but I
also mean and I mean this and I think I
can and I might and I really mean that
and I also think I mean jack [ __ ] and
once you get that [ __ ] balance [ __ ]
gets good and I think that's what you
have I mean that I appreciate and I feel
I feel so much the same before though
like that's kind of what I meant about
my benchmark being low as in my ambition
is super high like equally I want to get
us out there to thousands and thousands
of people I want this to be a continued
global movement I feel amazing every
time I see it grow but my benchmark is
low in the sense of I'm here I'm like
waking up each day and in those small
moments we have which is just literally
being aware for one another each day the
way we interact with one another each
day is where it's at for me I just
thought of something three days ago
I'm so pissed like d-roc you around good
so three days ago one of the most
interesting things happen just on this
point that you're making I was getting
out of the car and I looked at the guy
who was sitting in a truck it was like a
rugged looking dude and I looked at him
and I smiled and he smiled back at me
and I just remember thinking like
because I do it all I'm just happy and I
do I [ __ ] love smiling at people
because one I live in New York and so
like that just [ __ ] with people in
general but it is one of the you know
it's it's the might it's a much more
lightweight micro version of what you're
saying but it is stunning how much
people enjoy if you look them dead in
the eye while walking by them in the
airport or on the street and smile at
them how stunningly warm the real
reaction is by people and and I think
like I think about these things because
I'm like okay if I start really pushing
this
well then it's gonna become a tactic and
you know but then I'm like back to your
question like giving too much I'm like
but that's still good cuz that's better
than not doing like I think about this
[ __ ] all the time but I don't know it
hit me so I don't know why was this time
I don't know what the hell I sensed or
what you know what was going on it was
just it really like shook like you know
like I get goosebumps I like feel [ __ ]
sometimes I was like this was good there
was something there i need to i remember
thinking like what the [ __ ] d-roc like
we should have filmed this like you know
and I'm I I think it's I think this is
an important topic I really I really do
think this is an important topic and by
the way I think the macro anxiety and
tension in our world today politically I
think is the is a tremendous thing I
just want everybody know I think it's a
tremendous thing
one man's point of view because I think
it's our one step backwards for two
steps forward because I think we're
being exposed completely yeah and that's
exactly and I feel like if you believe
that which I think everyone this room
will believe mental health Israel will
believe talk to one another is more
important you gotta believe there's
something like a smile is the antidote
to that because that stuff Israel and
there's this guy in there pork as a
never eat or the other day and he said
to me he was like you know it's funny
when you like do something for someone
and even this as small as just talking
or smile like you're not supposed to get
it back in that moment you're not
supposed to get it back right then but
they might want around the corner and
they might like give it to someone else
and he was saying this really simplified
way I'm like yeah that's it he knows
exactly what it's about
and he hasn't overthought it he just
knows if he gives it out there that's
gonna ripple and that ripple to the
start of your day that can affect your
creative your work great your success in
every way I truly believe that I think
that even though it sounds small it
sounds like me we might be feeling good
now cuz the smile is great but it's
literally I think it's a very real I'll
tell you how real I think it is I think
that 37 years ago which is five minutes
ago if we're sitting here and we're
telling everybody here that meditations
the [ __ ] were some weird monks from
[ __ ] India now every cool [ __ ]
hipster meditates every day and it's the
core of their [ __ ] existence right I
mean this I mean this I think that it's
really funny the timing of things that
are [ __ ] completely outlandish the
way we eat and exercise and mental every
that we now think is standard cool or
right 30 years ago with some left-field
[ __ ] just like being cut my entire
[ __ ] life at this point secretly is
to trick 15 to 25 year old alpha males
that nobody else can get to accept me
and trick them into understanding that
kindness and gratitude and empathy is
the foundation of an alpha winner sounds
ridiculous now I know what's going on
out there but I'm telling you I can
taste it I know it and I know I can do
it or at least my part and that builds
momentum and we were talking upstairs I
said we're talking a little bit about
scale I was like just [ __ ] execute I
generally believe that one woman one man
just executing just executing can
actually impact a lot of people because
I think when you do the right thing the
amplification becomes inevitable I
really believe that and I think now we
live in a world where so much is being
amplified naturally I think what we need
to be careful of when we get into great
stuff like this is the Catterick picture
of TOMS shoes can start out actually
giving back but then the manifestation
changes social media originally was a
sharing ourselves now we're the PR
agents of ourselves on those platforms
like literally somebody here is gonna go
[ __ ] hiking this weekend just for the
[ __ ] photo you don't want to hike you
need the Instagram photo showing that
you're hiking so we as humans can really
become caricatures the no question the
biggest thing I talk to myself about is
do not be to come the character sure of
yourself because of what's happening
with you which is why I don't consume
it's I do not get hired to [ __ ] own
supply your [ __ ]
just [ __ ] execute don't get caught up
yeah it's gonna ask like how you keep in
check with that each day but I think I
think you already answered it is like
being accountable they just generally
know that nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
when I die and it's super easy it's
super easy not to get two hires you can
read first of all what's I like reading
my negative comments way more than my
positive ones I mean it I mean it and I
don't think there are trolls and haters
I really don't I think that they've
consumed me in a contact
and I need to be thoughtful about what
they're thinking now I do believe I
equally believe that if you're taking
time to consume people's other people's
content on the internet and then you
have the energy to leave terrible
comments you're cut you're in a sad
place yourself you know so usually when
I read like Gary Vee you're a snake oil
salesman my first default is okay why
did they interpret this content this way
but even before I go there my alpha even
before that my first default is like I
feel bad for that person yeah and you
and you've just hit someone who you want
to reach right you know I mean in some
ways I say if I could if I click really
that's what I'm doing sue if I get that
comment where it's like oh yeah but
these people should get a job and all
their drugs and all their this thing and
that thing I'm like that's exactly what
I want to talk to you because otherwise
it wouldn't be doing what I'm doing
otherwise someone else just no Matt I
think I think it's right I think I think
also you just have to understand humans
humans only know two ways to build the
biggest building in town most people
strategy of building the biggest
building in town is by tearing down
everybody else's building there are a
few people who just go out put their
head down and try to just build the
biggest building and I think that uh for
whatever reason that thank God that
moment that my parents decided to have
sex and have a child that that default
DNA that I have that I've never the
thought of tearing down other people for
my success seems like such loser [ __ ]
like like when I watch other people try
to tear down the competitive landscape
for them to look big it's the biggest
tell of a loser and a lot of people get
micro big wins in that that model works
you could it works I think people get
confused it works in the short term it's
got no sustainability for legacy that
person always loses at the end always
but people are caught up in short term
ROI because you're insecure and you care
about other people's opinion like what
is the balance of you genuinely want to
do something good but you also have your
own whatever ambitions or wants or needs
I you know I think one of the biggest
reasons I talk way more about trying to
buy the New York Jets than I do about
all the good things I do is because I
think I've wanted to speed up the
interactions of not I don't I don't mind
that people think what they think and I
want to be I think transparency matters
I think most people's vulnerability that
are good humans are hiding whatever
selfish things they want for themselves
because they think it undermines their
good and I think you can carry two
contradictory things within a human
being and I think your work your life's
work will play out and we will judge in
the end I am outrageously interested in
being booed in the third quarter I just
want to be cheered when it's triple zero
you understand people struggle with that
because it comes down to self-esteem and
insecurities and many other things I
tell everybody that I meet along the way
that I think is authentic put your two
fingers in your ears execute in
perpetuity and let the [ __ ] chips
fall that's the only way you'll ever be
able to achieve something remarkable
because when you are doing anything
interesting or game-changing or like
different you're only gonna get I've
only been booed my whole life every
single thing I've done basically from
school to professionally I mean I took I
don't know if I've ever taken more heat
for not opening a second liquor store
with my dad like the entire liquor
industry which was my life right my
dad's liquor industry in New Jersey was
my life every one of those people
[ __ ] ridiculed the [ __ ] out of me for
selling liquor on the computer you're
pouring all that money and selling
liquor and the computer you should open
a second liquor store right so like I
think there's certain people
entrepreneurs givers politician there's
millions of people different kinds of
teachers there's certain people who are
just capable of doing that and I think
the reason I talk a lot about it is my
hope is if this one [ __ ] answer can
let them hear one less voice that's
moving the needle because you're either
on offense or you're on defense and
dwelling about other people's opinions
of how you live your life is defense and
I want to remind everybody the current
state of political correctness moves I
have no interest in living my life and
pay
renting my children on today's current
state of how you should raise your
children you raise your children your
way I'll raise my mind right and I think
that's something that I think anybody
doing something has to navigate the
other thing is I try to convince nobody
of anything I've zero interest in
convincing anybody that anything I say
is right like zero like people always
like Kari how do you convince the
clients to do social mean I'm like I
don't I tell them what I believe
hopefully they'll do something about it
and if not then I can't wait to see him
in seven years when I could tell them I
told you so dick you know like like I
really feel like I win either way every
time I really feel like that's what
happens I'll either be historically
correct and I'll raise you all these
kids that are not signing with Boehner
Sports right now right because me my
brother have the sports agency and we're
we're coming in second a lot because
they're enamoured but we're still new
and this agency that's been doing it for
40 years and did it for my favorite
player feels like a smarter bet it's
crazy I [ __ ] love it there's a thing
that came out about Kobe and Dwyane Wade
this weekend where Dwyane Wade was
talking about how he broke Kobe's nose
in an all-star game and he's like he he
like called him like a day later and
Kobe he was like no no I love it I love
that you [ __ ] broke my nose and
everyone just talked about how crazy
Kobe was and I was like watching that
videos like the [ __ ] I so understand
that the only thing I like better than
winning a piece of business is losing it
I genuinely enjoy it more I just wanted
to touch George or like III like for me
for me the best thing to do man is when
you when you feel that way or the
scenario you just described in gal your
scales and way up what feels better what
masks you more is the better way to
phrase it the good you're doing and how
that feels because again coming back to
your 10 or those people who hangers on
this side because guess what you're
gonna be I'm gonna be full up with that
no reason why you doing by the way
they're back to hater like I really you
know I'm really getting passionate about
this I'm really I don't know where I'm
going I'm almost doing this with all of
like you guys I'm passionate
about this haters trolls thing I think
people are quickly defaulting
immediately if somebody doesn't agree
with them and calling them a troll or a
hater and they they maybe but I think
it's very I mean I'm genuinely meanness
I take a lot of heat because I put
myself very out there but I genuinely
have become great friends with many
people that [ __ ] on me or have come to
understandings it's very important you
know like to be thoughtful like look you
somebody who might say you're a [ __ ]
jerk-off and you're just trying to build
a business you don't know if they're ant
committed suicide and that's like hurt
them in their heart and they're just and
you they know you're a business they
knew you before and you're been
entrepreneur you know you don't know I
just don't think we know I think we're
just I just I don't know I'm getting
very passionate about judgment I'm still
in my working stages on it but like it's
crazy I'm just like I have opinions I'm
a normal human being I got quick I got
hot takes on everything but I know
they're [ __ ] cuz I know even the
people I know super even d-roc who I
know super well man do I not know a lot
and so if that's the case the hell am i
doing with your one piece of content or
your one question or right like you can
go on intuition all this but like I
think we need to be more thoughtful
about pushback because it's been very
helpful for me like I think I don't know
I think it's important yeah and I think
you allow like through doing that you
allow yourself that like I wrote
something a couple of days ago were sent
to allow for like a strangest bad days
to allow for yours like catch me on
Monday morning about a coffee there it
is you know I mean it's like I'm gonna
be that person like definitely this week
or next or whenever
and I think empathizing one another is
sympathize with yourself and I think in
relation to what we're saying with
comments or you right I mean I think the
label is just hate is is actually what's
a human it's a human who is coming from
this place I'll be honest with you most
of the hate I get is when I if I'm very
fair and I try I really I enjoy and
swayam I think I am a pathetic I'm like
look this person saw this clip for one
minute on Instagram it's the only thing
they know about me I hid there explore
page I'm very self aware of my different
personality traits and when I have the
mic and you
I've got way more fire and bravado and
energy then if we're just sitting
one-on-one and it's only a minute and if
I didn't contextualize it perfectly it
can be out of context and me out of
context is a [ __ ] disaster as are
most people especially with me with
passions and opinions out of context big
[ __ ] trouble and so if I can see I
can see it through their eyes and then
there's also people that don't have
vested interest in you being right if
you sell television commercials in
America you don't love me you know like
and that's fine
and that's fair like I just I try to
educate right ooh have a conversation
with those people I have a lot of
friends who sell things that I don't
believe in and we'll have a beer and I'm
like look do you actually believe it
because some of my friends actually
believe that buying a television
commercial in 2019 is a the best use of
money to make something happen that I
love that means we just have different
points of view my bigger problem is
you're an SVP at a TV company you're
bonus on that business and you're only
saying it because that's what you're
currently selling and next month when
you're an SVP at Facebook you're
[ __ ] on TV that I've got a problem
with not really live your life you're
just not gonna win the long game because
you won't be historically correct so you
can damage your brand your reputation
and I think that matters I'm very proud
of like saying what I believe in I'm not
gonna always be right but I've never
said anything I don't believe in for
financial vested interest which is why I
don't feel vulnerable my number one
thing I can't wait for in the world
right now in the micro and business is
when I decide that social media is
overpriced like can't wait if Cambridge
analytical didn't happen it might have
happened sooner but I think I still got
three to five years but in 9 years with
no hair you're gonna see me on whatever
the Instagram of the day is and I'm
gonna be like you're buying [ __ ]
Instagram you [ __ ] and I can't wait
because that's when I'll be able to go
full circle because a lot of things that
I struggle with in marketing today are
the things I used to build Wine Library
Banner I used to get
14% click throughs on Wine Spectator
comm in 1997 14 like I loved banner ads
but I don't like them anymore
and things change and so the Yellow
Pages was the [ __ ] best that's why
everybody calls her company Triple A
everything because you showed up first
but um [ __ ] changes but I do think this
subject we're hitting on tonight is
going to be next I think there's gonna
be a lot more conversation that is I
think we're having a lair to
conversation around kindness giving
that's starting to manifest and that's
why I was excited to do it tonight who's
got questions give him the mic um so I
wanted to know your opinion on if there
was for example what you could create a
company that actually made income
helping people where you could then turn
that income and reinvest it into
creating other forms of ways of helping
people is that not something that would
be a positive way of doing something
I'll let you answer is well might might
be my hot read on that is first and
foremost everybody should do whatever
the [ __ ] they want like what my opinion
means jack-shit there are people like my
point of view is for me for me just me I
like to build things that are business
and then I get profits and with some of
those profits I like to do good things
I like separation Jab Jab Jab right hook
if somebody wants if to Blake who's a
great friend did TOMS shoes and the way
he liked and many people argue which one
has more scale whichever one has more
skills whoever executed better at their
thing
Bill Gates made a lot of money and give
it as giving it all the way and so is
Warren Buffett that's plenty of [ __ ]
scale there toms will never sell enough
shoes to beat Warren Buffett and his
giving back so like there's I think it's
about self-awareness what makes you
happy and what you think is right
working with Westminister we'll be
working how it all can kind of connect
together and obviously there's an outlay
to start this often yep going I've been
doing that myself but it will get to a
point yeah where you've got to try and
continue it so to be able to turn this
into a form of income whether I gotta
run itself for helping more people to
expect I got it with kind of I think the
question is please say if it's if I
guess is the question of I might think
it is elect more you mean like Marley
he's like the morale like is it okay to
be outside yeah for sure like I mean of
course you can you can like earn I mean
because otherwise you you're never gonna
be able to complete what you're complete
like finances resources are like what's
needed I'm slowly starting to realize
that keep doing one here by gradually
gradually you know no and I think
morally of course but who gets to be the
moral compass who's like like who lost
to idiots like what like that's what I
think everybody has to act like who like
for me personally it's when I go to
sleep do I feel good about myself to
myself I'm the judge and jury not my mom
not my wife not my kids and definitely
not you [ __ ] me me for me that's why
I love the rocky with [ __ ] Drago
right it's a moment that stuck with me
as a kid and now thirty [ __ ] years
later I understand it when he's standing
there and he's telling the [ __ ]
Soviet government you [ __ ]
weren't in the ring I was fighting for
myself not for you in this country I
don't I didn't understand I thought it's
because I was born in Russia and I love
the Rocky movies that but but 25 years
later somehow on some during the shower
or flight I remember when I remember
when I understood I'm like [ __ ] that's
why 13 year old [ __ ] me thought that
was such an important moment I'm playing
for me um the [ __ ] judge in the jury
right and how will I know that I'm not
delusional by how humans interact with
me right when people say to me well Gary
if that's the case how do you not become
insert and delusional and how do you
know I know by how people react but how
I make decisions is me and I think
that's what he's going to deal with like
when you start
on these things it's judgement it's the
judgment
you only know it's only binary brother
there is no half pregnant either you're
doing this because you actually want to
give you're doing this because you want
to give and make or you're doing this
because you want a disguise giving to
really make there's only three moves
it's it's and you're the only person
that's gonna know and I keep telling
kids all the time you may be able to
trick the 98% but it's the 2% that know
exactly what the [ __ ] you're doing that
you're eventually going to want to win
and you've lost because you've gone
short-term you've been thinking this cuz
it's awesome I'm sorry yeah no exactly I
agree with you I agree too but not you
like so altruism like do you mean
whether it's real isn't like are you
always kind of constantly thinking I
don't know whether this is legit cuz I
don't know if someone's doing this yes
alright alright you know what's really
fun that and what's really funny for me
is I have parents that are literally
polar opposites my dad is a 100% default
cynic my mom is a 100% optimist and I
understand it both so I look at
everything through both of their eyes
and so I understand so I've you know
I've I I'm to be honest I'm I'm grateful
that I skewed more towards optimism it's
what entrepreneurship needs you're
blindly optimistic like you can't do the
[ __ ] an entrepreneur does unless you're
delusional and optimistic right but
b-but I was so grateful that I got into
my dad's sphere of cynicism right
because what it did was it allowed me
not to become delusional
there's a level of practicality that
overlay toward it but to your point like
look my macro and this is very simple
human beings would have been gone a long
long long long long time ago if we
weren't massively by default good it's
crazy that we're still around by how
smart we are as animals like the like
it's crazy actually so but I get it I
understand and I think to your point and
I think you know what's interesting just
even listening to you talk I think
there's a you know some of these words
that we all throw around somebody did
something great for me they said hey
Gary use empathy a lot of times when
you're actually saying sympathy right
and I was like oh that's interesting you
know I kind of like you caught me right
I look I'm like oh that's true and so
like you know I don't know I I think
practicality is amazing I think I'm I'm
crazy practical it's why for 25 years
I've built businesses never borrowed
money never lost money or like I'm
always practical so and I think that's a
kissing cousin sometimes the cynicism
and I think you know I have a friend
who's like I'm cynic I'm like you're
practical you've got a little hint of
cynicism and I think you know those you
know I'm optimistic but I'm not
delusional yeah but it's funny for but
yeah but you know it's funny back to
definitions and why words and
wordsmithing matters and I was thinking
about it like if you asked me like
literally cynicism is the single thing
in the world I hate the most to just
default into the negative or by
definition feels like sucky but if it's
practicality just like I used empathy as
sim the times like I'm always one I'm
always just asked you know I'm curious
right like defaulting into like no
that's [ __ ] up they're tricking
everybody like everyone's drinking the
kool-aid that's cynicism hey watch out
for you know so those are just things I
think about
thank you Ben yes yes
yes yep yep so it's a great question one
it's like the best for D I mean the fact
that people call other human beings
they're d-roc at scale always makes me
smile so I like love that uh you know
couple things I remember the three
months that I debated them of myself if
I wanted a man to follow me around with
a camera everywhere I went as as
self-confident as I am as much as I have
my fingers in my ears as much as I don't
give a [ __ ] of what you guys think I'm
also not tone-deaf I was like holy [ __ ]
if I'm gonna start walking everywhere
with a man with a camera me boy is
everyone gonna think I'm a narcissistic
[ __ ] you know and so I had to think it
through and you I'm giving you the
answer to my question in story form the
biggest reason I actually finally took
the plunge it said [ __ ] it let's go
after de Rock was kind of pitching in
kind of whatever because we knew
vlogging was happening but it was all
Casey and others first-person this was
different was cuz I remember thinking
you know what I'm so happy that my great
great grandkids are gonna have this like
I lost both my grandfather's before I
got to know them the thought that by
chance either one of them would have
done a vlog for four years and I could
watch and I'm a big history will tell
you the future it would have just been
so valuable
every entrepreneur right now who's
vlogging who she or he thinks they're
gonna make it like me who don't have the
talent or the things of that nature or I
don't think anything's ever
oversaturated because I don't think the
world is about being first I think the
world is about being best I really do so
that doesn't bother me if everyone's
doing it I think wait I think of 13
years from now way more people gonna be
doing it like way way more I think the
fact that the booby prize that the booby
prize of you docking mending yourself
for seven years that you didn't pop and
you didn't become a public speaker or a
company didn't get huge but the booby
prize is that your grandchildren are
gonna have it is one of the best things
I think I've ever done in my life I
really believe that
you do oh that works for Ivan how does
another shells like man you look [ __ ]
great black definitely doesn't crack you
look great bro you you know that's who
I'm going after that's you know that's
what I'm going after like living a life
where you're comparing yourself to
somebody else [ __ ] sucks
isn't it it's just it's just devastating
and and that's why I have so much
cynicism towards the people that rent
Lamborghinis to make it look like they
own it to then sell kids cuz because
this is going to be a mental health
issue my number one fear no question is
what's about to happen I know that I'm
gonna have to go through a period of
time where people are gonna blame me for
things that I had nothing to do with
because entrepreneurship at scale is
gonna fail during the next economy
collapse and a lot of people are not
going to be able to deal with the
following right now on your Instagram
account it says you're an entrepreneur
you're manipulating your creative on
your Instagram so you're showing when
you're at parties or when you're with
somebody cool or you're taking five
thousand I mean the worst of the worst
you're taking five thousand dollars of
cash out of the bank and taking a
picture of you holding it all or you
know normal cliche alpha-male things and
females to be like you know and the
world's gonna melt and you're gonna have
to go from being this successful
entrepreneur on Instagram to going and
getting a job my fear is that there are
a lot of people that are not going to
have the mental strength to walk around
with that scarlet letter when you're
gonna have to go there and you're gonna
have to deal with that post because you
haven't posted for four months on
Instagram because you're not showing
your Lambo anymore and the comments
start streaming in like yo bro like just
last comment
you flossing like not flossing anymore
saw you working at the [ __ ] bank this
weekend I'm very and I don't mean kind
of um substantially worried about this
because I think we're talking about a
generation that was over coddled by
modern-day parenting who don't look at
adversity as a good thing they look at
it as a bad thing I saw a lot of you
react I'm telling you with my whole soul
go meet anybody who has known me for 40
years
I love losing I love it [ __ ] love it
I live for it here's why cuz I think I
deserve it if I play you one-on-one and
you beat me like what I [ __ ] lot like
I love the merit of the game so I love
entrepreneurship I like when my
companies fail or my strategies fail or
we lose a client I love it I mean it I
mean it I mean it I mean it literally
another text this is what so by the way
this is the the most intense part that
kid what you said earlier about being an
entrepreneur if you're actually an
entrepreneur meaning like it's your
company all your day is is a bunch of
[ __ ] you're the last line of defense
along with the [ __ ] context out of
place that I have to deal with
personally I get another text that we
lost a piece of business six hundred
fifty thousand in revenue and I knew we
were gonna lose it and I couldn't get
around to fixing it because I'm the CEO
I got a lot of [ __ ] going on and I loved
it because I was like mm-hmm I knew it I
couldn't get to it I should have got to
it I did a bunch of other dumb [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] stupid thing instead
of it if that's what I cared about I'm
being serious I don't have to your
actions are like manifest that's reality
I think it's what I'm most worried about
with these kids that are gonna fail and
can't be fake entrepreneurs on Instagram
anymore is they weren't brought up in an
environment where losing was good they
were brought an environment where losing
was bad and that's something I want to
change we I think we have to stop giving
seventh place trophies it's bad for kids
I told my son the other day my son is
all about sports now I told him right to
his beautiful little face the other day
I'm like he said to me dad how old am I
gonna be when I can dunk I said bro
you're never gonna dunk
he said why I said genetics but tennis
is great and it might be so you know or
he might buy a basketball team but but
what's really fun and this is now me
going through it right hypothesis are
cute executions different listening to
him three weeks later play with one of
his friends and he's telling his friend
to take jump shots like he's like no no
let's go out here and take shots he goes
and and he goes because we're never
gonna he put it on him to that kid won't
donkey there but but he goes cuz we're
never gonna dunk and the kid goes wide
goes because my dad told me and I just
keep playing it over in my mind me being
radically can Duras with him it's gonna
help him it's gonna help him be a human
that can deal with adversity and things
that don't come like like life and it's
gonna help him actually in something
he's passionate about because if he just
stays on the outside he could be a nice
little you know pickup basketball player
if he doesn't play around the rim like
every other idiot that never gets to
dunk and actually works on a [ __ ]
jump shot I don't know this is something
we need to bring back into society merit
accountability we need to put these on
pedestals not over coddling fake
environments
the only kids startups are being funded
by their parents but nobody's saying
[ __ ] and then that same kids [ __ ] on
their parents I mean there's so much
fucked-up [ __ ] going on this is why I
love the Internet it's exposing it's
getting hard to hide and it's gonna get
harder and harder and harder and
everybody's gonna hate it because
everybody's living life because of
shadows but when you get to the other
side of it when we stop being hypocrites
because we know that everybody sucks at
[ __ ] and everybody's got shortcomings in
130 years I'm so pissed I don't get to
be around for that cuz that's gonna be
[ __ ] amazing and I think a lot of
what you're doing is the matically and
what we're talking about here it's not
gonna matter how we're judged now it's
gonna matter how we're judged later
because that's where shit's gonna play
out yeah I think from that booga had to
like some of the stuff that I do is I
just think it's very important to
recognize like what you want in your
life what do you actually want like what
do you want what I go and talk kids in
school and stuff is like of course like
the first thing is well maybe I want to
be an influencer I want to be famous
want to do this want to be that it's
like because that's what's there and
that's one long form so important like
it's so important to have long form to
say yeah do you want to live out of a
suitcase for three months you know do I
haven't got TV like you know I mean like
as in like I'm just saying if you've got
to show the other side of that and I
think that's what's really important
here is not just the Mirage of what the
kind of one side of it is so yeah what
do you want what's your lifestyle like
what do you actually want is most
important and we're gonna get right to
you men but like but then it's demonized
the other way like I'm being demonized
because I believe in work ethic all
right
hustle porn work too much like
everything everything runs in trends
work ethic is not gonna be demonized
when the world collapses and everyone's
looking for jobs just won't for me you
know I don't know what the percentages
of the environment of New Jersey I know
it definitely affected the way I curse
disproportionately the way my mom raised
me is a lot I mean Freud kind of like
this has been established environment
nature-nurture didn't like these things
have been accept but like man [ __ ] all
of it look like I know it's not true
that it's all of it because there's all
there serendipities but [ __ ] so much I
am so outlandishly grateful for how my
mother raised me it's it's so in
conceding a book in my head that I will
write one day called perfectly parented
and it's gonna be from my perspective of
what she and my dad listen I'll tell you
this I'm gonna share something else so I
don't share a lot I'm in the zone right
now I was naturally more full of [ __ ]
than I am and it's probably why I'm such
a good showman it was my dad's insanity
that embellishment
forget about lying that embellishment
was like fraud my dad was so extreme
Eastern European like don't like like I
remember one times like he's like how'd
it go I was like we sold 39 cases and
they're like four days later is like we
sold 38 cases and like scared the [ __ ]
out of me I was like okay like like I so
I give my mom a lot of credit because
the great thing that happen to me is I
didn't know my dad for the first
fourteen years of my life because he
worked every minute and all his
negativity and cynicism and stuff didn't
affect me so I had all that optimism but
then I mean this is back to gratitude
right when I needed it because I was
starting to form right 1314 I'm starting
to really mold and I was a Salesman I
would say anything to you to get that
sale anything Santa Claus [ __ ] it like
you know like [ __ ] anything going
through the extremity of working with my
dad every weekend every holiday every
summer vacation those 45 minute rides
his complete and utter disdain for
embellishment let alone lying completely
changed the course of my life I think
that it's why I understand you know
sometimes when I have cynicism like ah
he's full of [ __ ] I'm like hmm I wonder
if they can sense what I was from 1 to
13 before my dad you know like you know
like the gift of gab and that when you
have the ability to communicate the way
I do you often end up bad because when
you have that level of Manilla
manipulation skill you tend to thank God
the inside was good which has allowed me
to manifest this way but you know what
happens I this is why when I talk about
like this is why I don't think I'm
anything I think I have nothing to do
with me when good things happen to me or
people think I'm special like my parents
that must be awesome feeling right cuz I
understand that when people say good
things about vaynermedia I feel good
I've operated and built that right when
people say good things about my kids I
will feel that with me it's like that's
Sasha and Tamara that's communism and
capitalism that's America in the 80s
that's Jersey you know that's my friends
that I stumbled across along the way but
in truth to answer your question
directly the most she made it happen
correct
yes I am a big byproduct of emotional
intelligence and work ethic an enormous
by-product me my mom and my dad make a
joke that we're working dogs my parents
don't how to relax our default is to
work we like it it's our hobby I would
like I like to work I'm sorry I don't
want to go skiing I do not want to go on
a yoga retreat I'm not interested in
being on twitch for nine hours unless
I'm psychoanalyzing the framework of 14
year old gamers you know like so you
know I think everybody gets to do what
they want that's back to judgment right
like I also don't you know this is when
I get mad when people think that I'm
pushing her too much
hustle I'm like you're not listening to
what I'm saying I say all the time just
be happy like make 46 thousand a year
and beyond ten softball teams if you're
pumped at home then you're good
you can't work ten hours a week and
expect to build a billion-dollar company
don't be delusional just like I have to
understand the ramifications of me being
here tonight is I'm not tucking in my
kids so like when they're 27 and they're
18 times closer to my wife I'm like like
you know so you just have to you have to
like that's what I like like life is
fair I believe in a way that I don't
know if other people do but so yes
that's what I do not because I think the
fragmentation of attention is different
than 1984 Madonna could do too much
exposure because there was only 37
places and if she kept doing it we would
get bored in today's world there's so
much as big as I am or as big as a shake
I mean as big as like Drake is like most
like it's so much fragmentation right
like you took you back to hip hop you
look at average 15 year old kids what
they like in hip hop like nobody knows
who they are because they're all
SoundCloud rappers right so like I think
no I do not look the music business is
predicated on a singular hit that
changes the course of your career so why
wouldn't you give yourself 365 chances a
year for that singular hit write it I'm
telling you this is ideology of the past
not this is everything for me right now
in society and definitely a business we
have not yet as a collective completely
understood what the internet is I'm not
I'm just being very basic like we it's a
young thing we're but just like the
macro brother
like everything we do is predicated on a
world that was predicated on print and
television and radio
now the Internet's number one it is and
so every rule goes the other way because
distribution is not limited distribution
was limited in the old world
so everything was formed around that
distribution in this world it's in
perpetuity unlimited so becomes a game
of best not first they'll never you know
and so yeah I think you should put out
as much [ __ ] Conte as possible let's
sneak in this I know we have two minutes
but go ahead sir okay I think if you
love doing what you doing you know I
mean I think that's what it comes down
to for me I only post about where I feel
like I only hit someone on Instagram
when I feel like doing it actually at
that time so it's always just based on
how I feel like I want to do what I do
and I'm pretty sure I know that's before
you it's that would have been my answer
into somebody very smart friend of mine
Tom Bell you on a podcast with me looked
me dead in the face rocked me rocked me
cuz it's true very similar to how you
pegged me with you know EQ and work
ethic he rocked me he goes do you know
what your superpower is I'm already
pumped like what you know like what is
it
and like what is it and you know and
usually in those moments I think he's
gonna say something like work ethic an
EQ would not surprise me that I'm super
understand but he looked at me goes your
superpower and I just and you have this
more than anybody I've ever seen
your ability to not judge yourself is
remarkable and that's my answer every
day my ambition is insane if I decide to
sleep all 24 hours in the next 24 hours
I'm thrilled it's a it's it is the
combination of those two I love what I
do and if today like my ability like and
this gets into a singular voice
mentality because I don't think most
people are actually judging themselves
either I think they're taking the voices
of others to allow themselves to be
judged people like Gary I hear you but
what if you're you know they're like I
get it don't listen to other
but what if your own voice the one in
your own head is telling you you suck
[ __ ] or do this town the other thing I'm
like you've taken on the voice of
someone else I really believe that
and for some reason through self-esteem
serendipity and many other things very I
mean I consciously in third grade
decided to not try in school not because
I was the normal third grader because I
definitely wasn't it was because I was
like [ __ ] this has nothing to do with my
life and I'm gonna start working on my
actual scale and I'm willing to deal
with the judgment of my teachers you
know I'm not fun it is to grow up your
whole life and have your all your
friends parents think you're a loser
because the only framework in society at
that time is your school grades I think
more kids have to learn how to be in a
framework of adversity because the
alternative is why we have so much
sadness which is parents are creating
fake environments kids have no adversity
and everything's taken care of in one
way or the other whether through
financial or delusion and then they go
into the real world and mommy and daddy
aren't around anymore are they thank you
[Applause]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club empathy this
project means the world to me that could
really use your support
you